bonjour j'espère que vous allez très
bien qu'on coup est ce que vous allez
très bien embêté la pierre trop de ma
chaîne youtube
aujourd'hui on est sûr qu'ils les tuent
c'est un jeu sur playstation 4 dans
lequel on va jouer avec nos téléphones
et je précise aussi que c'est un jeu de
la galette d'art de la gameplay à son
déjeuner se la joue comme ça le héros
s'appelle link il va y avoir plusieurs
thèmes pour le hockey tu as dit quoi 1
je crois que tu as dit enlève ton fait
non je rampe hockeyeuses par exemple un
thème le camping il va donc y avoir une
question par exemple lequel de vous
n'arrive pas à des pièces attend va
devoir chacun noté le nom de la personne
ok c'est parti c'est fou tout allait
bien ce matin mais ce coup-ci m ça y est
nous y sommes qu'ils proposeraient des
vacances dans un camp de tentes rouges
gagnent des points je vais miser sur moi
backline a tout inventé pour toi
pourquoi je me sens pourquoi vous avez
des points parce que quand tu es dans la
majorité tu as des points j'ai pas
compris attendait qu'est ce qui va te
brûle alors qu'ils profiter de vacances
en commun mais ne pas changer sous
vêtements tu m'écoutes versé avant la mi
temps j'ai entendu il a essayé de
m'expliquer sans s'énerver avant tout ce
qui va se passer on va voir que les gens
ont joué là tu vois on a dit que c'est
toi qui changerait pas de sous-vêtements
et carlito et mc fly on dit que c'était
maclife n'y a pas de soulever des
commandes du chef bastoi on sait qui a
joué sur quoi j'ai alors d'accord qui
s'apercevrait trop tard qu'on ne caresse
pas les loups ça c'est mon nouveau monde
et comment je vais faire deux buts hier
à illies à débat je suis me permettre
pourquoi vous pensez que je caressais un
dieu pourquoi parce que comme tu es
gamer c'est un peu l'amour donné ce que
tu serais genre allez voir le loup est
un jeu mais aucun rapport
allez on continue dans ont déboulé
riddick je vous le dis depuis tout à
l'heure tu l'as vu m'a traitée au genou
au genou les gars là je pense là
j'arrête là bas tout est là squeeze et
les campeurs regarder un peu hein
dans la vidéo
[Musique]
depuis dix ans cette photo et vous
connaissez un truc est un endroit où
quand on tape ça me fait absolument pas
mal je le fais rien hyper mal car litres
gros quelqu'un en photo on la reçoit sur
notre téléphone et il faut la dessiner
après un mois dans la nature pour
qu'elle endosse d'accord avec ses péchés
aux hyper stylé qui rire est à une
blague pourrie d'un prof qui coûterait
la colle heures de colle ou la vrai que
l'otan mais évidemment pas à tout et en
tout dans le score mettait au dessus
dans le coeur que freman fallait si le
prof sortait de la classe il embrassera
un enfant mineur regarde moi il
deviendra noir
pas de venir doubler encore jeu en
descendent les amis s'il vous plaît
avant de servir ont dessiné ce qui vient
dans le casier de mcfly
voyons un peu ce que vous avez dessiné
les costumes volant ok c'est une
trottinette ternoise on savait pas
d'être aulas jeux d'imitation
alors bonjour c'est anne roumanoff rien
on alors qu'avec une gêne aux jeunes
image quel animal représente le mieux -
carlito en à mort via un animal qui
devait arriver quelqu'un en photo pour
dessiner avec un cadeau pour son
vainqueur montré moins parce que ça
donne mais arrêtez de notaire qui a fait
ça ces quatre jeunes oui mais personne
n'a voté pour mon cochon mon cochon il
méritait oui oui je peux redire ma
phrase de tout à l'heure j'étais en
dessous dans le score mettait mois il
valait pas plus t'es quoi j'ai découvert
quand on sait que ce que je veux dire ma
phrase gentille pour nathalie mais bien
sûr matou tu as
tu fais ce que tu veux avec ces infos
natale et ça m'a fait mal là tout tu m'a
foutu une belle rihanna blanche quel
rôle endosserait atout dans un braquage
9,1 braqueurs d'un braqueur d'un tracker
ou d'un vieux
le plus beau les navets des crêtes en
attendant ma faute j'ai un gros avec un
gros coeur un poireau s'est bien oui est
ce que l'on veut faire une petite
deuxième game
oui n'oubliez pas des fois vous avez des
jo cas vous pouvez les mettre et sa
double les points de gagner sauf dans
les deux auteurs à qui ne pourraient pas
s'empêcher de désinfecter sa couchette
avant de s'y installer
vous savez je suis comme toi écoute bien
quand j attends c'est pas chez moi je
sais où la femme de ménage de l'asthme
entreprises dans lesquelles je travaille
ronge les produits ménagers je vais
nettoyer l'intégralité des chiottes
allait bien dedans je dis pas qu'il faut
pas dire d'anecdotes et ou en tout cas
faut qu'elle fasse au moins un tiers de
ses missions mais drôle qu'il organisait
une fête dans le wagon-lit croyant
festival quels travaux faits pour faire
c'est le meilleur à vous mes pensées un
humain en cette phrase et deuil arrêtées
de tricher bonne hygiène la planète
[ __ ] les beaux maire vous avez joué la
même chose non je vais mettre au milieu
tu bouges pas fait gaffe aux gars trop
petit chat with y prend quelqu'un en
photo pour pouvoir le dessiner un
conducteur de rien
[Musique]
mal notée cette image ce jeu est cool il
fait partie de la gamme d link beijing
linkedin alors quelles mutations la
meilleure a pas gardé fois de plus dit
miao canet c'est la fin de cette vidéo
n'hésitez pas allez messieurs elle vous
a plu c'était qui es-tu un jeu on refait
on refait c'est la fin de cette vidéo
n'était alors c'est quoi je vais quitter
[Rires]
la vidéo n'était pas les laisser vous a
plu passez voir et j'ai nommé
fredericton atouts cimetière par le
jeans à mes attentes j'ai prochain à
vidéo
oui